are you a fan of steam's early access
program wish you had more options for
playing games before the full release
then you'll be glad to hear that CD
projects gog.com is getting its own
version of early access the new feature
is called games in development and it's
being handled the GOG way that means CD
Projekt is hand picking which games will
be available and you can refund any game
within two weeks no questions asked the
first five games to enter the program
are Starbound ashes of the singularity
project zomboid terratec and the curious
expedition regarding the new program dog
managing director put karwowski said our
goal has always been to offer a
selection of titles that are both
excellent and worth your time nowadays
we're seeing more games that are already
great experiences while still in
development we want all gamers on
gog.com to have access to what these
titles have to offer but we want to get
it right carefully evaluating each and
every game offering a 14-day refund
policy and providing dog galaxy support
with update rollback and more the games
and development program launches today
January 28 and the first round of games
are all on sale when CD Projekt
announces more titles or changes how the
program works you'll hear about it from
gamespot